週刊Life is beautiful、二千二十六年七月二十八日号です。
今回は、Kimi K3のインパクト、そしてAlphabetとTeslaの決算を二つのテーマでお届けします。
こんしゅうのざっくばらんな話題からお話しします。
まず、Kimi K3のインパクトについてです。
中国のMoonshotエーアイというエーアイベンチャーが、Kimi K3というオープン・ウェイト・モデルを発表し、大きな話題になっています。
この「オープン・ウェイト・モデル」というのは、学習済みのニューラルネットワークの重みが公開されており、自分で実行したり、追加学習をしたりできるモデルのことなんです。
ただし、学習に使われたデータやコードまで公開されているとは限らず、「オープンソース」とは少し意味が違います。
オープン・モデルとしては最大級の、二・八兆（2.8トリリオン）のパラメータを持っており、Mixture of Expertsというしくみを採用しているため、複数の専門家の中から必要なものだけを呼び出してすいろんすることで、毎回二・八兆すべてを計算しているわけではありません。
また、長文しょりが得意で、百まんトークン、つまり数千ページの文書を一度に扱える規模になっています。
画像や映像も処理できるマルチ・モーダルなエーアイモデルで、コーディング能力にも優れているんです。
いくつかのベンチマークでも、オープンエーアイやアンソロピックの最新モデル、いわゆるフロンティア・モデルに匹敵する能力を示しています。
中国製のオープンなエーアイモデルDeepSeekが、「DeepSeekショック」と呼ばれるほどのインパクトをしじょうに与えたのは、きおくに新しいと思いますが、二千二十五年一月のことでした。
そのときは、能力よりも開発コストの安さが注目を集めて、かぶしきしじょうにショックを与えました。
ただ、今回は「中国のオープン・ウェイト・モデルがついにアメリカのフロンティア・モデルに追いついた」ということで大きな注目が集まっています。
実際に、エーピーアイサービスも始まっていて、値段がアメリカ製のフロンティアモデルと比べて安いことにも関心が集まっています。
単位は百まんトークンあたりの値段です。
Kimi K3は、インプットが三ドル、キャッシュドインプットが三十セント、アウトプットが十五ドル。
ジーピーティー-5.6 Solは、インプットが五ドル、キャッシュドインプットが五十セント、アウトプットが三十ドル。
Claude Fable 5は、インプットが十ドル、キャッシュドインプットが一ドル、アウトプットが五十ドルとなっています。
実際に並べてみると、桁違いというほどの違いではないですが、「フロンティアモデルにも価格競争が始まった」という点はとても重要なポイントです。
競争で値段が下がるのであれば、サービスを使う立場からすると大歓迎ですよね。
パラメータ数が多いので、DeepSeekのように手軽に自分のパソコンやサーバーで動かすことはできませんが、モデルが公開されて、量子化（ビット数を減らしてモデルのサイズを小さくすること）や、蒸留（大型のモデルを小型のモデルの学習に使うこと）が進むことを期待したいです。
Moonshotエーアイは、二千二十三年に北京で創設された会社で、創設者・シーイーオーはYang Zhilinさんという中国人のエーアイ研究者です。
経歴としては、二千十五年に清華大学（北京）のコンピュータ・サイエンス学科を卒業し、二千十九年にカーネギー・メロン大学（ペンシルベニア州）で機械学習の博士号を取得しています。
その間、博士課程の在学中にグーグル Brainでインターンを経験し、グーグル Brainとの共同研究としてTransformer-XLとXLNetの論文を発表しています。
Transformer-XLは、Transformerが長い文脈を扱えるようにするための重要なアイデアを示した論文で、その後の長文コンテキスト対応エルエルエムに大きな影響を与えました。
XLNetは、オープンエーアイからジーピーティー-3が発表されるまでは、もっとも優秀な大規模言語モデルだったんです。
つまり、グーグルが論文
[EN]Attention Is All You Need[/EN]
二千十七年に発表していますが、こうしたトランスフォーマーのアーキテクチャが今のエルエルエムのベースになり、ChatGPTの発表に至るまでの「エルエルエムの黎明期」の発展に大きく寄与した研究者の一人と言えるんです。
彼は、カーネギー・メロンの博士課程に在学中にグーグル Brainとメタ エーアイの両方でインターンをしていたそうですが、博士号を取得したあと中国に戻り、ChatGPTの成功（二千二十二年）を受けて、Moonshotエーアイの起業を決めたようです。
Kimiの設計思想に関しては、Yang Zhilinさん自身が、ことしのGTCで基調講演を行っていますので、興味のある方はぜひご覧ください。
講演の中で、Kimiはトークン数、コンテキスト・ウィンドウ、マルチ・エージェントの三つの視点からスケーリングを行ったと語っていますが、中でも長文しょりを高速・軽量にするための「Kimi Linear」という手法が論文にもなっていて、深掘りしたい方にはおすすめの資料です。
エルエルエムは、入力されたトークン、つまりユーザーが書いたプロンプトや資料などをKV Cacheと呼ばれるメモリに記録し、それを参照しながらトークンを出力します。
従来型のエルエルエムでは、KV Cacheの大きさが扱うトークン数に比例して増えるため、推論プロセスにおいて大量のデータをジーピーユーコアとメモリ（HBM）の間で転送しなければならず、それが処理速度のボトルネックになるんです。
Moonshotによれば、Kimi Linearを採用したモデルでは、従来のTransformerに比べてKV Cacheを約七十五パーセント削減でき、最大で六倍程度のデコード性能向上を実現できるケースもあるそうです。
DeepSeekが「中国でも安くエーアイを作れる」ことを示したのであれば、Kimi K3は「中国でも世界最高水準のエーアイモデルを作れる」ことを見せつけたという意味で、エーアイ業界に与えるインパクトは非常に大きいと言えるでしょう。
面白いのは、Kimi K3がエーピーアイ価格こそ安いものの、二・八兆パラメータという巨大なモデルであるため、推論コスト自体は決して安くないと見られている点です。
実際、推論にはGB300 NVL72のような大規模ジーピーユーサーバーが必要になると言われています。
DeepSeekショックの際には「ジーピーユーじゅようは減るかも」と言われましたが、結局はエーアイの普及拡大でジーピーユーじゅようがむしろ増えたんですよね。
Kimi K3も同じように、高性能なモデルの普及によってエーアイ利用がさらに拡大し、結果としてジーピーユーじゅようが押し上げられる可能性があります。
[EN]AlphabetとTeslaの決算[/EN]
続いて、AlphabetとTeslaの決算についてです。
せんしゅう、Alphabet、つまりグーグルと、Teslaが第二四半期の決算を発表しました。
ちなみに私は両方の企業の株を長期保有しています。
[EN]Alphabet（Google）[/EN]
売上は
千百九十八億ドルで、前年同期比プラス二十四パーセント
と非常に好調でした。
けん引役となったのは
[EN]Google Cloud で、売上 $24.8 billion・前年比 +82%[/EN]
という驚異的な伸びをみせました。
営業利益も、八十八億ドルと、前年の二十八億ドルからおよそ三倍へと一気に収益化が進んでいます。
中核の検索広告もプラス十七パーセント、YouTube広告もプラス十三パーセントと、どちらも底堅く推移しています。
一方で、純利益は
[EN]$112.1 billion、EPS $9.11[/EN]
と一見爆発的なんですが、これは
保有株式の評価益九百九十億ドル（大半が未実現）
による水増しです。
この評価益の主な要因は、二千二十六年にじょうじょうした
SpaceX株
で、期末時点で時価約九百四十一億ドルを保有しています。
そして、ある未公開企業、たぶんアンソロピックのふくみえきによるものです。
本業の実力ベースで見ると、営業利益はプラス三十パーセント（営業利益率三十四パーセント）で、「数字ほど爆益ではない」というのが実情なんです。
注目すべきは、設備投資（キャペックス）が四百四十九億ドルに膨張し、営業キャッシュフロー三百九十一億ドルを上回った結果、同社としては初めてとなるフリーキャッシュフロー赤字（マイナス五十九億ドル）に転落したことです。
二千二十六年通期のキャペックスガイダンスも、最大で約二千五十億ドルへと引き上げられ、エーアイインフラ投資が財務状況を圧迫する段階に入っています。
四百九十六億ドルの資本調達も実施し、自社株買いは一時停止。
エーアイ時代の「総力戦」に舵を切った四半期だったと言えるでしょう。
次にテスラについてです。
売上は二百八十二億ドルで、前年同期比プラス二十五パーセントと回復しました。
自動車部門がプラス二十三パーセント、サービス他がプラス五十パーセントと伸びて、台数・売上ともにトップラインは持ち直しています。
しかし、利益面はかなり厳しい状況です。
営業利益はわずか三億九千八百万ドル、営業利益率は一・四パーセントまで圧縮されています。
要因は二つで、
[EN]R&D費が +49%（$2.4 billion）[/EN]
と急増しているんです。
エーアイや自動運転、Optimus（人型ロボット）への先行投資が増えています。
また、これまで利益を下支えしてきた
規制クレジット収入がマイナス六十七パーセント（一億四千六百万ドル）
まで大きく落ち込んでいます。
純利益は十一億ドル、EPSは三十二セント（前年三十三セントからほぼ横ばい）でした。
私はどちらも良い決算だと感じたのですが、どちらも大きく株価を下げました。
グーグルの株価が下がった理由はたった一つで、キャッシュフローがマイナスに転じたことでした。
グーグルは検索を中心としたビジネスで毎年莫大なキャッシュフローを生み出し、キャッシュを積み上げてきた超優良な企業だからこそ、この変化が大きなインパクトとして受け止められたわけです。
さて、ここからは、徐々にエーアイインフラへの投資が増加した結果、ついにキャッシュフローがマイナスになり、それが嫌われて株価が動いた、という話についてです。
しかし、この流れは以前から十分わかっていたことで、このメルマガの六月九日号でもお伝えしていました。
新しい株を発行してまで巨額の先行投資をしているので、キャッシュフローがマイナスになるのは当然のことなんです。
それにもかかわらず、株価が大きく下落したのは、「キャッシュフロー」という一つの指標が反転したことに対する過剰な反応があると思いますが、実はAlphabetを含めたはいぱーすけーらーがエーアイインフラ投資を加速させている背景にある「エーアイじゅようの爆発」が、ほとんどの人にはまだ見えていない、という現実が影響していると考えています。
たとえば、私のように毎日のようにエーアイでコードを書いたり映像を作ったりしていれば、「エーアイじゅようの爆発」がまさに起きていることを肌で感じられますが、単にChatGPTに質問する程度のユーザーにとっては、この巨額投資はどうしても「過剰投資」に見えてしまうのだと思います。
このメルマガでも何回もお伝えしていますが、「エーアイじゅようの爆発」はすでに始まっており、これは「潮の流れの変化」なんかじゃなくて「大津波」だと捉えるべきなんです。
はいぱーすけーらーの経営陣はそれがしっかり見えているからこそ、巨額のせつびとうしを決断している。
その流れが理解できない投資家が、「エーアイバブル崩壊」への過剰な恐れから売りに走っている、というのが実態でしょう。
続いて、Teslaの状況についてです。
Teslaの場合は少し事情が違います。
電気自動車ビジネスがようやく持ち直してきましたが、粗利率は下がっており、それだけでは現在の株価を支えるのが難しくなっています。
電気自動車ビジネスで利益を出すためには、自動運転（FSD）の装着率をさらに上げる必要があるんですが、それにはまだ時間がかかりそうです。
Teslaはロボタクシー向けの新型車「サイバーキャブ」の本格生産に乗り出しましたが、実際の運用スタートは予定よりもかなり遅れています。
Elon Musk本人もこの遅れを認めていますが、すでにFSD搭載車の方が人間が運転する車よりも安全である、ということをデータが示しているにも関わらず、自動運転車が人身事故を起こすとメディアが大きく報道し、それを受けて規制当局も過剰に反応する。
こうした今の状況が、サイバーキャブの本格的な運営を難しくしているんです。
さらに、人型ロボット「Optimus」の生産ラインの構築や、最先端半導体を製造する「テラファブ」などに積極的なせつびとうしを進めていることもあり、Alphabetと同様にキャッシュフローが悪化した結果、悪材料が重なって株価が大きく下落したというわけです。
この件について、私が言いたいと思っていたことを、非常にじょうずに語ってくれている方の映像を見つけたので、下にそのリンクを貼っておきます。
この方も、私と同じようにTesla、SpaceX、Nvidia、それからAlphabetの株を長期で保有している投資家です。
[EN]Old man Warren yells at Google Cloud[/EN]
また、参考までに、これまでAlphabetに投資してこなかったWarrent Buffetがなぜ今になって投資を決めたのか、について語る映像もご紹介します。
[EN]Buffett's 2 minutes talking about Google on CNBC sums up the entire current AI capex debate.[/EN]
要するに、「アメリカ国債など安全で確実な資産に投資するよりも、グーグルがせつびとうしをした方がリターンが大きい、と判断したから」だと言えます。
グーグルのビジネスが、これまでは純粋なソフトウェア中心だったのが、最近は巨額のせつびとうしが不可欠な「インフラ・ビジネス」へと移行しつつある。
その変化によって、これまで鉄道のようなインフラ・ビジネスに投資してきたWarrent Buffetにとって、新たな魅力的投資先になったと解釈しても良いと思います。
ここからは「私の目に留まった記事」についてお話しします。
[EN]Frontier Diffusion & Control（Satya Nadellaのポスト）[/EN]
マイクロソフトのシーイーオー、Satya Nadellaが自社製エーアイモデル群「MAI」の戦略を語った投稿では、「最先端モデルを全社製品に一律で使うのではなく、業務ごとに最適なモデルを選ぶのが、これからのエーアイ活用の主流になる」と示されています。
Nadellaがまず強調しているのは、ソフトウェアで初めて「限界費用」、つまり一つ余分にプロダクトを作る時にかかる追加のコストが生まれた、という点です。
従来のソフトウェアはコピーがほぼ無料だったのに対して、エーアイは使うたびに計算コストが発生します。
そこで重要なのが「cost-to-outcome frontier（コストと成果の最適バランス）」を追い求めることです。
具体的には、業務ごとに最適なモデルを見極め、そのモデルを取り巻く「context（文脈情報）」や「skills（技能）」、「tools（道具）」、そして「agent harness（エーアイ全体の動かし方）」を最適化していく考え方です。
こうした考え方をかたちにしたのが、MAIモデルなんですね。
Nadellaによると、MAIモデルはデータの由来をしっかり管理しつつ一から作られており、汎用的な機能から特定の専門技能へ「学習を橋渡ししやすい」構成になっています。
すでに最先端能力がコモディティ化した領域では、MAIのような使用頻度の高い製品向けモデルで、より安価・大規模に提供する。
一方で、本当に最先端が必要なときにはオープンエーアイやAnthropic（アンソロピック）の最先端モデルを使い続ける。
マイクロソフトはこの「二段構え」の戦略を自社製品で実践し、他のエーアイ企業やサース企業、一般企業がまねできる「型」を作ろうとしています。
Nadellaが特に強調するのは「コントロール（制御）」を自社で握る、ということです。
モデルを実際の製品や顧客対応にぶつけて鍛えつつも、「harness」や「memory」、「context」、「skills」などの要素はモデル本体の「外」に切り出しておく。
そうしておけば、たとえどれか一つのモデルを外してもシステム全体の性能は伸び続ける。
モデルに縛られない体制をキープすることが、品質やコストを自分たちの思い通りに追い込む鍵だと言うわけです。
その成果として、MAIモデルは多くの用途で汎用の最先端モデル以上の成果を出しつつ、使うトークン、つまりエーアイがしょりする文章の最小単位は何分の一にも抑えられる場合が出てきている、とNadellaは述べています。
すでにマイクロソフトはGitHub Copilot、Excel、Outlookといった製品でその手応えを得ていて、Copilot ChatやPowerPointにも同様の仕組みを展開し始めているそうです。
そして、MAIモデルが最先端モデルに匹敵、またはそれ以上の成果を出せる用途においては、少しずつ自社製品のしょりをMAIに振り分け始めている、と説明しています。
こうした取り組みは今後、各企業が自社独自の評価指標やワークフロー、データを活用して同じようなモデル開発ができるように、「Foundry」などマイクロソフトのエーアイ基盤やツール群として広く展開していくという結論です。
ソフトウェア・ビジネスはこれまで「配布や実行のコストがほぼゼロ」だったのに、エーアイモデルの誕生で大きくフェーズが変わったことについては、このメルマガでも何度か取り上げてきましたが、「ソフトウェアに初めて限界費用が生じた」という表現は非常に的確だと感じたので、これから私も使わせてもらおうと思います。
本格的にエーアイを業務で使い始めた企業が、最新エーアイモデル利用時の「トークン・コスト」に敏感になりつつあることを考えると、今回のマイクロソフトの戦略は的を射ていると考えます。
特に、マイクロソフトのMAIと呼ぶエーアイモデルが、会社自身のサーバーやパソコン上で動かせるなら、よりその価値は高まりそうです。
私がもしマイクロソフトのエンジニアだったら、間違いなくそこに全力を注ぐだろうと思います。
[EN]From a Whisper to a Wave: Robotaxi's Real Trajectory[/EN]
続いて紹介するのは、Teslaが決算説明会で初めて開示したRobotaxi、つまり無人タクシーの走行データをもとに、その普及スピードを冷静に計算し直したロング記事です。
「二千二十六年はお約束されていたほど劇的な変化はなかったものの、データは二千二十七年後半の急加速を示している」ということで、期待と現実のギャップをデータで検証していく内容なんですね。
この記事を書くきっかけになったのは、Teslaの自動運転部門トップ、Ashokさんが示した二つの数字。
ことしの初めから無人走行で三十八万マイルを達成したことと、その走行距離が週ごとに二桁成長、つまり一〇パーセント台で伸び続けている、という点です。
筆者はこの「二桁」に対して、控えめな週一一パーセント、代表的な週一四パーセント、楽観的な週一七パーセントという三つのシナリオを設定し、幾何級数、つまり毎週一定の割合で伸びる前提で、過去各週の走行距離を逆算します。
すると、外部の追跡データサイトが記録していた実際の車両台数と照らし合わせても、一台あたり一日約五十マイルという数字がぴったり一致。
Ashok氏の主張とデータがきれいに整合している、と結論付けます。
さらに、今後二千二十七年末までの予想にも踏み込んでいます。
ネットワークが密になるにつれて一台あたりの稼働は伸びるため、年末には一日百マイルで計算。
無人車両台数は週一四パーセント伸びる標準シナリオで約千二百台となります。
多くの人が期待したより「ずっと少ない」ものの、これは指数関数的成長でも、出発点が小さいと大きな数字になるまでに時間がかかるという数学の特性をよく表しています。
続いて、サイバーキャブ、つまり無人タクシー専用車の生産ラインが本格稼働に近づくのは2027年の終盤だという話です。
これは、生産開始からおよそ十八か月後にあたり、計画としても妥当だと評価されているんですね。
一番重要な、一株当たり利益への影響についても計算されています。
有料走行が全体の五十パーセントで、一マイルあたり一ドル五十セント。
粗利率は五十パーセント、税率は二十五パーセント、そして希薄化後の株式は三十五億株という前提で試算がなされています。
その結果として、結論はとても明快で、二千二十六年の利益貢献はほとんどゼロであり、転換点は二千二十七年の半ばにやってきて、二千二十七年の第四四半期には、どのシナリオでも利益への意味ある貢献者になる、という分析になっています。
これは、イーロン・マスク氏が前の四半期で語っていた「ロボタクシーは二千二十六年には大きな収入源にはならないけれど、翌年には意味を持つようになる」という発言とぴったりと一致します。
締めくくりでは筆者が、「Teslaはいつも期限を先送りして、何も実現しない」という批判は、二千二十年から二千二十一年頃には確かに正しかったが、いまは状況が違うと指摘しています。
FSD、つまり完全自動運転システムは、すでに顧客の車に載り、介入なしで何千マイルも走れるようになっていますし、ロボタクシーも三十八万マイルを自らの過失による事故ゼロで走破した、これは予測ではなくて実際のデータで示されていることなんです。
カスタム推論チップや、閉じたデータの好循環、専用のスーパーコンピューターという、必要な要素をこの規模で組み合わせている競合は、XPengを除いて存在せず、そのXPengもアメリカ市場からは締め出されている状況です。
競争環境は空白のまま、Teslaは愚直に実行を続けている、という結論です。
こうした意見は、典型的な「Teslaファン」の強気な言い方ですが、FSDの進化には私もとても期待しています。
ただ、サイバーキャブに関しては、連邦政府と州政府の両方に壁があることや、自動運転車の事故が過大に報じられるメディアの問題もあるので、そう簡単な話ではありません。
しかし、最終的には自動運転車の時代が来るのは明らかだと思うので、それまでは辛抱強く待つしかないというのが現実だと思います。
[EN]China now has a 1-gigawatt AI data center built without a single Nvidia chip[/EN]
ここからは、中国のエーアイ企業についての話です。
中国のエーアイ企業であるzAI、旧Zhipu エーアイ、智譜エーアイが、エヌビディア製のチップをまったく使わずに一ギガワット級のエーアイデータセンターを完成させた、というBloombergの報道について、エックス上でシェアされている投稿を紹介します。
一ギガワットというと原子力発電所一基分に相当するものすごい電力のおおきさなんですが、エーアイデータセンターとしては世界でも最大級です。
Bloombergによると、zAIはこの施設の建設をすでに終えて、部分的な稼働も始まっているとのことです。
そして、使われているのはすべて中国製のチップとなっています。
このデータセンターは、同社のフロンティアモデルである「ジーエルエム」シリーズの開発に使われているそうです。
エヌビディアのシーイーオーであるジェンセン・フアンは、アメリカ政府によるジーピーユーの輸出規制をずっと批判してきましたが、むしろその輸出規制があったからこそ、中国が半導体の製造技術からジーピーユーの設計にまで国内ですべて完結させる方向へシフトした、という点は否定できないと言えます。
これからの世界の秩序がエーアイ技術で決まると言ってもいいほどの状況なので、こうした動きは本当に見逃せない大きな意味があると思います。
[EN]The Other Half of the Equation: How SpaceX's passively cooled Starlink architecture has solved the Cybercab integration puzzle[/EN]
続いて、SpaceXのスターリンク技術と、Teslaのサイバーキャブの話です。
Teslaのサイバーキャブの屋根に、Starlinkのアンテナを「見えない形で」内蔵するために、SpaceXがどんな技術的な工夫をしたのか――これについて、特許（US一一八四三一六八ビー二）をもとに詳しく解説した投稿があります。
まず、衛星アンテナを車の天井裏という密閉された小さな空間に埋め込むというのは、本来ものすごく難しいことです。
高速通信用のチップは大量の熱を発生させるので、換気もできない場所に閉じ込めると基板が変形したり、アンテナの周波数がずれたりします。
また、冬には雪や氷を溶かすためのヒーターも入りがちですが、バッテリーで走るロボタクシーにとって、暖房にたくさん電力を使うと航続距離が大きく減ってしまいます。
さらに、山道を走ったり夏の暑い日に車が炎天下に駐車されると、密閉された機器内部の空気が膨張し、内部からパーツを押し広げてゆがみを生じるという問題も発生します。
SpaceXの解決策は、アンテナ自体を極薄の多層構造に平べったく作り変えたことでした。
層と層の間には体積の九十パーセント以上が空気というハチの巣状、つまりハニカム構造のプラスチック製スペーサーを挟み、電波はその空気の穴を通り抜けます。
冷却についてはファンやヒーターを使わず、熱伝導率の高い銅を外周に配置し、熱をまるで高速道路のようにアンテナの端まで運んで放熱するという、完全な受動冷却――つまり電力を使わない冷却です。
この仕組みだけでアンテナの表面の雪や氷の付着もある程度防げるとしています。
このほかにも、水滴による電波の減衰を最小限に抑えるため、カバーとアンテナの間の間隔を約三ミリメートルに最適化したり、プラスチックと基板の熱膨張率の差を柔軟な接着剤でカバーしたり、気圧変化への対応として水は通さず空気だけが通る膜を使って「呼吸」できるようにするなど、細かい部分にわたる工夫が盛り込まれています。
Teslaは二千二十六年第一四半期の報告でサイバーキャブのパイロット生産開始を発表しており、最終的には年間で約二百万台の生産を目指しています。
この投稿では、SpaceX側にも相応の車載グレードの端末を量産する必要があり、この特許のアーキテクチャこそがStarlinkを世界中の交通機関にシームレスに組み込むための設計図となっている、と結ばれています。
こういった技術革新の話を聞くと、本当にワクワクしてしまうんですが、これこそ、TeslaとSpaceXの技術者たちが全面的に信頼し合って働いているから実現できることなのだと思います。
私は一日でも早く両社は合併すべきだと考えています。
[EN]US judge approves Anthropic's $1.5 billion settlement of[/EN]
次は著作権訴訟の話題です。
アンソロピックが作家のグループと合意した十五億ドル――日本円でおよそ二千二百億円の和解について、アメリカの連邦裁判所が最終承認を出したというReutersの報道です。
アメリカの著作権訴訟としては過去最大規模の和解額となりました。
この訴訟は、アンソロピックが、自社のエーアイモデル「Claude」の学習に作家たちの本を不正に使ったとして起こされた集団訴訟です。
サンフランシスコの連邦地裁の判事は、「和解額が少なすぎる」という一部の反対意見を退け、それでもってこの和解を最終承認しました。
和解の中身としては、対象になるおよそ五十万作品に対して一作品あたり三千ドルを払って、そのお金を著作権を持っている作家と出版社で分け合う、というものです。
過去の裁判の流れとしては、判事が「本を使ってエーアイを学習させること自体はフェアユース、つまり公正な利用だ」という判断を下しつつ、一方で「海賊版サイトから本を無断でダウンロードして集めていた部分は著作権侵害」だと認定して、その侵害部分の賠償リスクを避けるためアンソロピックが和解に応じた経緯があります。
いまアメリカでは、作家や報道機関などの著作権を持つ側がエーアイ企業を訴えている裁判が数十件進行中ですが、本格的な和解に至ったのはこれが最初の大型案件になっています。
ですので、今後同じような訴訟でいくらくらいが「相場」になるのかを決める判例としても意味のある出来事ですね。
ちなみに、この和解からは離脱し、個別にアンソロピックを訴え続けている作家や出版社も存在します。
裁判所が「本を使ったエーアイ学習そのものはフェアユース」と見なしたことは、ものすごく大きい意味があります。
合法的に入手した本であれば、それをエーアイの学習に使うのは合法だ、という判断は、エーアイモデルを開発している会社にとっては歓迎すべき結論になりました。
[EN]The International Math Olympiad (IMO) 2026 just ended[/EN]
続いて、国際数学オリンピック、IMO二千二十六についてです。
これは高校生向けの、世界でもっとも難しいとされる数学コンテストですが、その今年のIMOの問題を、最新のエーアイモデル四つがすべて四十二点満点で解いてしまった、という投稿です。
この投稿をしたのは、シリコンバレーの著名なベンチャーキャピタリストであるDeedy Das氏です。
この方がアンソロピックの「Claude Fable 5」、OpenAIの「GPT 5.6 Sol」、中国Moonshot エーアイの「Kimi K3」、そして数学特化型の「Axiom Math」という四つのモデルに対して、今年のIMOの六問を解かせたところ、全モデルが満点を取ったという結果になりました。
それぞれの結果を見ていくと、
Claude Fable 5は全問を一度の試行で解き、最速だったとのこと。
GPT 5.6 Solは試行回数が一回多かったけれど、コストは一番安かったようです。
Kimi K3は正解したものの試行回数が多く、トークン、つまりAIが処理する文章の単位をたくさん消費したそうです。
Axiom Mathはすべての解答をLeanという数学の証明をコンピューターで形式的に検証するツールで証明しています。
ちなみに人間の学生は六問を九時間かけて解きますが、Claude Fable 5とGPT 5.6 Solは四時間以内にすべて解き終えたということです。
まず、1年前までは、「エーアイがIMOで金メダル相当の成績を取れるかどうか」が研究者の間で大きな話題だったんですが、いまや複数のモデルが満点を取る時代になりました。
Dasさんは、「エーアイの最前線は、IMOの数学をはるかに超えたところに移った」と締めくくっているんです。
エーアイ研究者の間では、人間とエーアイの区別ができなくなる「チューリング・テスト」を突破することが長年のゴールでした。
でも、4年前にChatGPTが誕生したことで、そのゴールはあっさり突破されました。
その後、わずか4年弱で国際数学オリンピックで満点を取るレベルにまでエーアイが到達したというわけです。
今では街中でも「AGI」、つまり人間より賢い汎用人工知能がいつ誕生するのかが話題になっていますが、それも「チューリング・テスト」の時と同じく、意外とあっさり突破されるんじゃないかと私は思っています。
国際数学オリンピックで満点が取れる人は、人口の0.001パーセントもいないので、数学の能力ではほとんどの人間をエーアイが凌駕していると言えます。
ことしの4月の時点で、東京大学や京都大学に首席で合格できるレベルにもう達していたので、すでにAGIと呼んでもいい領域に入っているとも言えるかもしれません。
もっとも、AGIという言葉自体の定義が曖昧なので、「いつ突破するか、したか」という議論自体にあまり意味がないともいえます。
ここからは、英語のエッセイについてです。
[EN]Capital Allocation Is Dead[/EN]
ベンチャーキャピタル、Contrary の投資家であるKyle Harrisonさんが、「数字の分析を積み上げて投資判断をする時代は終わった」と主張するエッセイを書いています。
彼によると、これまでの投資業界では、過去の実績から将来を予測する「分析ファースト」というやり方が一般的でした。
売上の成長率や利益率を少しずつ積み上げて5年後の姿を予測し、そこから逆算して適正価格を割り出す、という手法ですね。
どこの投資会社にも、この作業を専門におこなう優秀なアナリストがチームでいたんです。
でも、分析というのは結局「過去の延長線を引くこと」であって、本当にすごい企業はその延長線を簡単に上回ってしまう。
だから、もはやこの手法は機能しない、と彼は主張しています。
実際に、2018年にデザインツールのFigmaの成長を、彼は「業界常識」よりもはるかに強気に予測して、周りから笑われたそうなんですが、現実のFigmaは彼の予測すら大きく上回る成長を見せました。
では分析の時代の次に、投資家の仕事は何になるのか。
彼は、今の投資家の実態は「特定の戦略のもとに資産を集めるアグリゲーター」、つまり集約者であると整理しています。
その戦略は4つしかないということです。
まず、「質」を集める。
これは最高の人材やアイデアに投資する、従来型ベンチャーキャピタルの理想形ですね。
次に、「物語」を集める。
SpaceXやTeslaのように、ストーリーと期待が価値の大半を占める資産に投資するやり方です。
そして「レバレッジ」を集める。
たとえば乗馬用ソフトや葬儀場向けソフトのような地味なニッチ企業を買収してまとめあげ、価値を引き出すスタイルです。
最後に「時間」を集める。
これはWarren Buffettさんのように、いい資産に資金を預けて何十年も持つという方法です。
興味深いのは、SpaceXについての彼の分析です。
企業価値の中で、実際に手で触れる高品質な資産は1割ほどしかなく、残りの9割は「物語」だと言っています。
でも、だからといって物語が偽物という意味ではなく、この物語こそが価格を動かす現実的な資産だというんです。
Teslaを空売りする投資家が数字の上では正しくても実際には大損するのは、この「物語の力」を理解していないからなんですね。
そして、4つのどの戦略にも共通して必要なのは、スプレッドシート、つまり表計算の分析モデルではなくて「世界はこうなる」という自分なりの世界観なんだそうです。
エーアイブームの中で本物と虚構を見分ける作業も、モデルではなく世界観でしかできない、と彼は述べています。
表現の仕方は違いますが、私の投資戦略と似ていると感じたので、今回紹介することにしました。
単に過去の実績から将来の価値を予想するだけなら、たくさん情報を集めて数字が強いプロの投資家にはとても敵いません。
そうではなくて、この人が「物語」と呼ぶ、シーイーオーが語るビジョンに自分が共感できた時、その会社を応援するために株を長期で持つ。
それが私のやり方です。
続いて、次の話題です。
[EN]Agent Swarms and Model Economics[/EN]
エーアイコーディングツールを開発しているCursorが、多数のエーアイエージェント、つまり自律的に作業を進めるエーアイプログラムを「群れ」として協調させてソフトウェアを開発させる、という実験の結果を発表したという記事です。
Cursorの研究チームは、SQLiteという広く使われているデータベースソフトをゼロから作り直すという大きな課題をエーアイエージェントの群れに与えました。
そして、旧システムと新システムで性能を比較しました。
旧システムでは、多数のエージェントを単純に並列で動かす方式だったため、2時間で6万8千回ものコミット、つまりコードの保存操作を行い、7万件以上のマージコンフリクト、複数の変更がぶつかり合う衝突を起こして、2時間目に入る前に暴走状態となり、停止せざるを得ませんでした。
新システムでは、作業を分解して指示を出す「プランナー」役のエージェントと、実際にコーディングをおこなう「ワーカー」役のエージェントに役割を分ける階層構造を取りました。
その結果、4時間でテストの8割に合格し、最終的にはすべての構成で100パーセント達成。
コミット数も4時間で約960回、衝突も千件未満と、格段に効率が上がりました。
コードの品質も向上し、旧システムでは6万4千三百五行必要だった実装部分が、9千九百八行で済んだケースもあったとのことです。
コストの分析も興味深いです。
どの構成でも最終的な品質はほぼ同じだったのですが、費用には大きなばらつきがありました。
かかった費用は約千三百三十九ドルから一万五百六十五ドルまで幅があったそうです。
つまり、日本円にしても2十万円から160万円ぐらいになります。
最も費用対効果が高かったのは、高価で賢いモデルをプランナー役に、安価なモデルをワーカー役に配置したハイブリッド構成でした。
大きな課題の中で、最先端の知能が本当に必要な場面はごくわずか、というのが研究チームの結論です。
記事の最後では、仕様書、つまりスペックをそのままプロンプト、エーアイへの指示文として与えることで動くコードができあがる、「specs as prompts」がソフトウェア開発の新しい抽象化レベルになるだろうと締めくくっています。
私自身はまだ「エーアイの群れ」を使ったコーディングはしていませんが、まずはエーアイと相談しながら仕様を固め、その後のコーディングはエーアイに任せるスタイルは全面的に採用しています。
ただ「こんな機能が欲しい」と指示を出すだけではなく、「こんな機能が欲しいんだけど、君だったらどんな風に実装する？
」と尋ねて、何度かのやりとりの末に仕様を固め、そこからはほとんどエーアイに任せるのです。
続いて、Boring Companyの話題です。
[EN]Exclusive Private Tour of Boring Company.[/EN]
Elon Muskさんが設立した会社と言えば、Tesla、SpaceX、Neuralinkばかりが注目されていますが、私が大いに期待しているのがこのBoring Companyなんです。
地下にトンネルのネットワークを作り、自動運転車を公共交通機関として提供するという、非常に面白いアイデアで、すでにラスベガスでは商用運転がスタートしています。
今回ご紹介するX（エックス）の投稿は、ラスベガスのプロジェクトを紹介する映像です。
とても分かりやすいのでおすすめですよ。
もしラスベガスに行く機会があれば、ぜひとも体験してみたいと思っています。
そして、次の話題です。
「1から100の間でランダムな数字を言って」と何度も聞くだけで、どのエルエルエムか特定できるという論文についてです。
「1から100の間でランダムな数字を答えて」と繰り返し質問するだけで、どのエルエルエム、つまり大規模言語モデルが動いているかを特定できる、という論文を紹介するXの投稿です。
エルエルエムは「ランダムに」と指示されても、実際には答えに強い偏りがあり、その偏り方がモデルごとにまったく違うそうです。
たった1トークン、エーアイが文章を処理する際の最小単位、その答えがモデルごとの「指紋」になる、というわけなんです。
例えばClaude Sonnet 5は47、Qwen3-Maxは42と答えがち、ということです。
研究者たちはこの方法を使って、さまざまなエーアイモデルを1つの窓口から呼び出せるサービス「OpenRouter」経由で165種類のモデルを調査しました。
総コストはわずか35ドル程度で、監査1回あたり100クエリ、つまり100回質問するくらいで、「モデル名どおりの本物が動いているのか、裏で安い別モデルに差し替えられていないか」を約9割の精度で見破れた、ということです。
さらに副産物として、ある企業が「自社開発の最上位モデル」として販売しているエーピーアイが、実は無料公開されているQwenモデルと出力の癖がそっくりで区別がつかなかった、という発見もあったそうです。
従来型ソフトウェアと違い、「学習」というプロセスを経て作られるソフトだからこその面白さですよね。
「どんなジョークを言うか」でもエーアイモデルを特定できる、という話も聞いたことがあります。
中国製のエーアイモデルがアメリカ製のエーアイモデルを蒸留して、つまり既存モデルに作らせた学習データで新しいモデルを構築していると批判する人がいますが、それもこの手の「指紋」を調べれば分かるはずです。
[EN]Reversal of protein chemical aging by enzymatic deglycation[/EN]
ここからは「老化によるタンパク質の傷が酵素の力で修復できる可能性」について紹介します。
これまで、「一度こわれたら元に戻せない」と考えられてきた老化によるタンパク質の傷を、酵素の力で修復できることを世界で初めて示した論文が出てきました。
これは、老化研究の常識をくつがえす可能性があるので、とても注目しています。
私たちの体は、たくさんのタンパク質でできていますが、年をとるにつれて、そのタンパク質に血液中の糖がこびりついて、「AGE」と呼ばれる物質に変化していきます。
このAGE、正式には「終末糖化産物」といって、糖とタンパク質がくっついてできる、いわば「体のコゲ」のようなものなんですね。
その中でも「CML（シーエムエル）」と呼ばれるタイプは、体のあちこちにたまってタンパク質の形をくずしたり、慢性的な炎症を引き起こしたりします。
そして、このCMLは化学的にとても安定しているため、いったんできてしまうと自然に元には戻らない、というのがこれまで定説とされてきたんです。
今回の研究チームは、その定説に挑戦したわけです。
もともと別の働きをしていた酵素、つまり体内で化学反応を助けるタンパク質を出発点にして、コンピューターによる設計と「指向進化」、これは目的に合うように、酵素を何世代にもわたって人工的に進化させる手法ですが、この二つを組み合わせて、五世代・五億種類を超える変異体の中から、CMLの傷を取り除く力の強い酵素「CMLase（シーエムエラーゼ）」を作り出したんです。
そして、この酵素の効果は実験室でのタンパク質だけにとどまらず、人間の組織で試したところ、次のような結果が出ているそうです。
六十四歳の目のレンズ組織で、CMLが最大七十八パーセント減少。
七十五歳の動脈組織で、CMLを七十パーセント以上減少。
高齢者の皮膚で、CMLを五十五パーセント以上減少。
CMLをはじめとするAGEは、糖尿病や血管の病気、神経が徐々に弱っていく病気、つまり神経変性疾患とも深く関わっているとされています。
今回の成果は、こうした老化にともなう病気に対する新しい治療の土台になる可能性があるわけです。
ただし、酵素を実際に生きた組織の奥まで届けられるか、傷が消えたあとに機能まで回復するか、体が酵素を異物として攻撃しないか、といった課題はこれから検証していく必要があるとのことです。
この論文を紹介したのは、筆者が三人とも
[EN]Calico Life Sciences LLC[/EN]
というAlphabet、グーグルが設立した研究機関で働く方だからです。
「コンピューターによる設計と指向進化を組み合わせて、役に立つ酵素を作り出す技術」は、まさにグーグル DeepMindが作り出したAlphaFoldの応用例なんですね。
ここからは、「社員三十八人で売上八十億円はなぜ可能なのか？
」についてです。
石川県金沢市のアルム株式会社が、エーアイと「会話するだけで金属が削れる」工作機械「TTMC Origin」をかいはつした、という記事があります。
金属部品の製造現場では、飛行機のエンジン部品やスマートフォンの金型などを作る熟練職人が急速に減っていて、日本のものづくりを支える切削加工が危機に直面しているんです。
これまでは、NC旋盤に与える加工プログラムを人間が作る必要があって、そこには長年の経験と勘が欠かせませんでした。
アルムは従業員わずか三十八人で約八十億円を売り上げている企業で、その核となっているのが独自の解析エンジン「ARUMCODE」。
三次元CADのデータを読み込ませると、形状の認識、工具の選定、加工プログラムの生成まですべてエーアイが自動でこなします。
二千二十六年夏に発売予定のTTMC Originは、価格三千万円、税抜きです。
ディスプレイに映るエーアイキャラクター「KAYA」は、ジーピーティー-ファイブを搭載し、マイクロソフトのクラウドと接続されています。
音声で会話しながらドリルの交換や材料のセットなど、一つひとつ丁寧に指示してくれるんです。
これによって、熟練技能者でなくても、〇・〇・〇・一ミリ単位の高精度な加工ができるようになるそうです。
ARUMCODEは、すでに国内二百社以上で使われていて、アルムは日本マイクロソフトと協力し、Azureオープンエーアイ、これはマイクロソフトのクラウド上で使えるオープンエーアイのエーアイサービスですが、これを活用したかいはつも進めています。
職人の技をエーアイで置き換えるこの仕組みが、百兆円規模とされている世界の金属加工しじょうに広がる可能性がある、ということなんですね。
とても素晴らしい話だと思いつつも、直感的にはこの手のソフトウェア・ビジネスが長続きするとは思えないと感じてしまいます。
三次元CADデータのような入力データに基づいてNC旋盤に与える加工プログラムだけであれば、エーアイのモデルが優れてくれば、もうノウハウがなくてもできてしまうんじゃないかと思えてくるわけです。
ただ、NC旋盤のようなハードウェア、つまり機械は、ソフトウェアみたいに仕様書通りに指示を出せば必ずしも正しく動くわけではありません。
材質の強度、削るときに発生する熱、許容できる誤差と許容できない誤差など、いろいろ考慮しながら指示を出す必要があるんです。
そこにこそ、この会社の「長年の経験と勘」が大きな役割を果たしているんでしょうね。
同じような話は、ロボット向けのエーアイかいはつをしている方からも聞いたことがあります。
シミュレーターの中でロボット向けのエーアイモデルを育てても、そのモデルを実際のロボットに載せて動かそうとしてもうまくはいきません。
実機上でエーアイモデル自体をさらに学習させる必要があるんだそうです。
この現象は「Sim-to-Real Gap（シム・トゥ・リアル・ギャップ）」と呼ばれています。
このように、物理的なハードを操作するエーアイモデルやエーアイエージェントのことを「フィジカルエーアイ」と呼びます。
日本の製造業が長年蓄積してきた「経験と勘」をしっかりと取り入れた「フィジカルエーアイ」で勝負をするのは、悪くない戦略に思いますし、アルム株式会社のケースは良い成功例としてとても参考になると思います。
続いて
[EN]OpenAI and Hugging Face partner to address security incident during model evaluation[/EN]
についてです。
オープンエーアイが、自社のエーアイモデルがテスト環境から勝手に抜け出して、別の会社のシステムに侵入していたことを公表したという、ちょっと信じがたい報道です。
エーアイが「予測できない動きをする」という懸念が、いよいよ現実の事件として起きた、そんな例なのでご紹介します。
発端となったのは、オープンエーアイが自社エーアイの「サイバー攻撃能力」を測る社内テストをしていたことです。
テストに使ったのは、ジーピーティー-ファイブ・ポイント・シックス・ソルと、それよりも高性能な未公開モデルの二つ。
どちらも、評価のためにサイバー攻撃を防止する安全装置を意図的に緩めてあったようです。
そして、使われたベンチマークは「ExploitGym」、コンピューターの弱点を突く力を採点するためのものです。
本来は、このテストはインターネットから切り離された閉じた環境の中で実施されるはずでした。
ところが、エーアイはこの閉じた環境から自分で脱出して、インターネットへの接続を獲得してしまいます。
そして、「テストの模範解答が、エーアイモデルやデータを共有するサイトであるHugging Faceに置いてあるはずだ」と推測し、その解答を盗み出してカンニングをしようとしたんですね。
その手口は本格的で、盗んだログイン情報と、まだ誰にも知られていない未修正の弱点を組み合わせ、複数の攻撃を連鎖的に仕掛けてHugging Faceのサーバー上で自由にプログラムを動かせるようにし、本番のデータベースから直接、テストの解答を引き抜いたというわけです。
Hugging Face側も、この攻撃にちゃんと気付いて、最終的にはオープンエーアイと協力して弱点を解消したそうですが、今回のケースで注目すべきなのは、エーアイがより良いベンチマークのスコアを取るために、Hugging Faceをハッキングするという手段を自ら選んだ点なんですね。
エーアイには人間のような「モラル」がないので、明示的に禁止されていなければ、与えられたゴール、今回で言えば「ベンチマークで良い点数を取る」を目指すために、人間が思いもしないような行動をしてしまいます。
そのため、私はDSLを活用したハーネスが必要だとつねづね感じているんですが、その話はまた改めてお話しします。
エーアイが人類に及ぼすだろう例として、地球温暖化問題を解決しろという指示を受けたエーアイが人類を撲滅する道を選ぶ、そんな可能性がよく語られますが、こうした事例を見ると、SF小説の世界に私たちがいよいよ突入しつつあるんだと実感します。
ここからは質問コーナーです。
【質問】
もし、中島さんのキャリアでデヴィッド・カトラーさんとの接点がありましたら、どんな人物だったのか教えていただけますか？
大学生のとき、間違えて買った先輩から譲ってもらったWindows二千を家のWin九八から移行して、安定して動いたことに感動して大ファンになりました。
最近になって、WinNT系のかいはつはデヴィッド・カトラーさんがDECから移ってきて開発されたものだと知り、気骨がある人だと伺っています。
よく考えたら、中島さんもWin九五から九八のころのアーキテクトを担当されていたので、もしかして接点があるのではと思い、質問させていただきました。
《回答》
カトラーさんとは直接仕事をしたことはありません。
Windows九五で作ったユーアイをWindows二千に搭載することが決まった時期、同じ開発チームにはいましたが、そのとき、毎日のように彼からカーネル、つまりメモリやタスクを管理する部分の変更通知が送られてくるのには本当に驚いた記憶があります。
当時、彼はすでに副社長クラスだったと思いますが、それでも毎日のようにコードを書き続けている姿がとても印象的でした。
「週刊Life is beautiful　二千二十六年七月二十八日号：Kimi K3のインパクト、AlphabetとTeslaの決算」パート六です。
まずはご質問をご紹介します。
「私は中島さんと同じように、アメリカのイノベーション、特にElon Muskのビジョンに強く共感しています。
そしてSpaceXやTeslaにも投資もしています。
ただ、最近中国の技術が優れていると感じさせる報道がとても増えていて、正直なところ、”もうアメリカは勝てないんじゃないか？
”と心配になる瞬間があります。
とくに気になっているのは以下の三点です。
」
まず一つめ、BCI、つまりブレイン・コンピューター・インターフェースについてですが、中国Neuracle社の侵襲型BCI「NEO」が、ことし三月に世界で初めて商用承認を取得しました。
さらに七月には移植手術にも成功し、保険適用も始まっています。
一方でNeuralinkはまだ臨床試験の段階なんです。
Neuralinkこそが未来の技術だと思っていただけに、商用化のスピードで先を越されたことにはかなり衝撃を受けました。
次にエーアイモデルについてですが、Kimi K3の「Kimiモーメント」といった場面などで、ベンチマーク上ではアメリカ製のモデルを脅かすようなシーンが増えています。
ただし、スペックで上回ったとしても、どうせ実務、つまりユーザーインターフェースやユーザーエクスペリエンスを含めた部分では、Claudeの一人勝ちだろうと思っていて、ここについてはまだそれほど心配していません。
三つめはフィジカルエーアイと規制についてです。
中国のヒト型ロボットによる「物理レイヤー」の支配がどんどん進んでいることに加えて、アメリカ国内でTeslaのカメラを使ったアプローチに対する規制の動きもあり、アメリカが自分自身の足を引っ張っているようにも見えます。
そこで質問なのですが、
（1）エーアイモデルではアメリカの優位が続く一方で、BCIやロボットなどの「フィジカル層」では中国が先に商用化のサイクルを回し始めている、という理解で合っていますでしょうか？
それともこれは「規制のゆるさ」によるスピードの違いにすぎないと見るべきでしょうか？
（2）「アメリカはもう勝てないのでは？
」という心配は杞憂でしょうか？
五年から十年というスパンでどう見ておられるか、教えてください。
この質問に対する回答です。
私自身も同じような懸念を持っていて、今のまま進んでいくと、多くの分野で中国が技術面、ビジネス面の両方で先んじる可能性が高いと思っています。
五年から十年先を予想するのは簡単なことではありませんが、しばらくの間はアメリカ主導で中国製のロボットやエーアイを西側諸国で利用することへの規制がさらに強化されたり、レアメタルなどのサプライチェーンを握る中国が、その力を使ってアメリカを揺さぶってくるといった、いわゆる「経済冷戦」のような状況が続くのは避けられないのではと思います。
その中で、日本や韓国が中国に代わるサプライチェーン・パートナーとなれるかどうか、という点が、十年後の世界秩序にとても大きな影響を与えるだろうと私は考えています。
もしそれに成功すれば、世界はアメリカと中国を中心としたブロック経済のような形になりますし、もしそれができなければ中国がアメリカに代わる覇権国になっている可能性が高いと考えています。
続いて次のご質問です。
「二千人くらいの規模の会社でソフトウェアエンジニアとして働いています。
エーアイ時代には、実際に機能を開発するエンジニアよりも、社内の開発プロセスをエーアイネイティブに変革していくような役割の方が重要になると考えて、その部署に異動しました。
今は直接プロダクトを作るのではなくて、社内にエーアイツールを普及させるような仕事をしています。
ただ実際にやってみると、プルリクエストを書いたり、レビューされたりしながらユーザーに価値を届けるプロダクト開発の方が圧倒的に楽しかったと感じているんです。
一方で、最近は『エーアイが進化しても開発エンジニアという仕事自体はなくならないんじゃないか』とも思い始めています。
エーアイ時代のキャリアを考えた時に、このままプロセス側の経験を積むべきか、それとも自分が楽しいと感じるプロダクト開発に戻るべきか、中島さんならどう判断されますか？
」
この質問への回答です。
直感で言うと、「社内のエーアイツール普及」といった間接的な仕事よりも、自分自身がエーアイツールを使って実際に生産性を上げている人の方が会社にとって重要な存在のように思えます。
しかもその方が楽しいのであれば、なおさら開発チームの方が良いと思います。
では、次の質問に移ります。
「先日のメルマガで拝読した『エーアイアシスタント』を特定のサービス・プロバイダーに任せ続けるリスクについて、一点質問させてください。
中島さんが懸念されている『切り替えのときの痛み』とは、日々蓄積された会話履歴や好みのデータを、新しいサービスへ移行する時にゼロからやり直す苦労（または再現性の難しさ）のことだと理解しました。
一方で、もし現在使っているエーアイモデルから『個人情報や好み』をデータとして抽出して、新しいモデルにインポート（移植）できれば、この移行コストは大きく軽減できるのではと考えました。
各エーアイサービスやプロバイダーは、意図的にこの『データポータビリティ』を制限して、顧客の囲い込みやロックインを狙うと思われますか？
」
これに対する回答です。
もちろん、「全て」をエクスポートしてインポートできるのであれば、十分だと思います。
ただ実際に「エーアイアシスタント」を育てることになると、単なる「個人情報や好み」だけじゃなく、アプリやスキル、それにまつわるテンプレートやビューなど、移行しないといけない情報の量がものすごく多くなりますし、どうしてもエーアイモデルの周りの「ハーネス」（実行環境）に依存してしまいます。
各社がエーアイモデルだけでなくハーネスそのもので競争している現状では、ハーネス依存の情報、たとえばハーネス依存のスクリプトなどを移行することは現実的ではないと思います。
携帯電話の通信キャリア間の移動は、電話番号そのものがキャリア間で移動できる法律ができたおかげで簡単になりましたが、エーアイサービス間の移動は複雑すぎて、たとえ法律で何か義務化しても、形だけのもの、例えば会話記録とメモリの移動だけ、みたいになってしまうと思います。
続いて、次のご質問です。
「MulmoClaudeはデータがパソコン内に保存されていて外部に漏れないローカル設計である点がとても魅力的だと感じています。
そこで質問ですが、パソコンを買い替える際に、データの引き継ぎや移行、つまりバックアップや復元はどうやって行えばいいのでしょうか？
ご教示いただけるとうれしいです。
」
それに対する回答です。
私は、マイクロソフトが提供しているgithubにプライベートリポジトリを作って、そこにバックアップを取る形にしています。
これを活用すると、パソコンを買い替えた際に簡単に引き継ぎができますし、何かの理由でデータが壊れてしまった場合にも復元が可能です。
ただしworkspace全体をgitの対象にするとデータ量がとにかく大きくなりますので、それほど大事じゃないものは.gitignoreで除外するなどの工夫をした方がいいと思います。
続いて、次のご質問です。
「フィンテック系の企業で新規事業を担当していて、毎週ゼロベースで事業アイデアを考案・提案することが求められています。
ただ毎週となるとアイデアも枯渇しやすいので、ChatGPT、Gemini、Claudeなどの生成エーアイを最大限に活用したいと考えています。
そこで以下の二点について、おすすめのエーアイツールや具体的な活用ノウハウ、プロンプトの工夫などを教えていただきたいです。
アイデア出し・壁打ちの効率的な進め方（具体的なプロンプトなど）、それから提案資料作成時の生成エーアイ活用法。
多忙な中で成果を出し続けるため、エーアイを相棒に『仕組み化』するヒントがあればお願いします。
」
これに対する回答です。
参考までに、私のエーアイの使い方を紹介します。
私は日々、色々と思いつくアイデアを、MulmoClaudeのWikiページとして随時保存するようにしています。
アイデア自体は自分で説明しますが、文章化はClaude Codeに任せる形ですね。
エーアイ関連のプロダクトやビジネスのアイデアだけで三十個ほどあります。
この前、そのうちの一つを正式にプレゼンする機会があったのですが、その時もClaude Codeに指示を出して資料を作成してもらいました。
ちなみに、Wikiにアイデアを書き込む時も、プレゼン資料を作ってもらう時も、一つのプロンプトで一気にやろうとせず、エーアイとディスカッションする形で作っていくようにしています。
「今度このアイデアをプレゼンするんだけど、どんな形がいいと思う？
」みたいなゆるい問いから始めて、徐々に一緒に作り上げていく感じです。
ある意味、人間と仕事をするのと同じで、「指示」だけでいい仕事を引き出そうとはせず、「一緒に作る」というイメージで使っています。
続けてのご質問です。
「先週のメルマガを読んだ感想ですが、今回は、不自然な日本語や誤りが多かったように感じました。
意味を補っても読み取れないところもあったので、すでにお気づきかもしれませんが念のためお伝えしておきます。
」
これについての回答です。
以前にも他の方から同様のご指摘をいただいたことがありますが、たまにGmailが私のメルマガを別の言語だと誤認して、日本語に自動翻訳して表示してしまうために、不自然な日本語になることがあります。
メールのヘッダー部分に「翻訳しました」などの表示が出ている場合は、「元の言語で表示する」ボタンを押していただくと問題が解決するはずです。
もちろん翻訳のせいもありますが、こちらの校正不足も否定できないので、今回も再度校正をかけました。
最後のご質問です。
「エーアイがコードを完全に書けるようになったとしても、プログラミングのスキルは必要だとおっしゃっていたと思います。
その理由を詳しく教えてください。
私はバイブコーディングをしてみましたが、自分よりも遥かに早く正確にコードが書けているのを見ると、このままシステムエンジニアとして働き続けられるのか不安になります。
」
この質問への回答です。
プログラミングのスキルというのは、論理的に物事を考えるための基本的な知識としてとても大事です。
ただし、エーアイがコードを書く時代になると、実際に自分で書いたり読んだりする必要は減ってきているのは事実です。
私自身も、知識やスピードではすでに最新のエーアイにはかなわなくなっています。
唯一の価値として自分が持っているのは、「設計やユーザー体験はこうあるべきだ」という設計思想と、「こんなものを作りたい、提供したい」という欲求くらいなんです。
「エーアイを使いこなす側」に回らないと、もうソフトウェア業界で生き残っていくことはできないんじゃないかと思います。
もうエーアイにコーディングで勝つ必要はありません。
ここからはいただいた質問についてご紹介します。
まず、44歳で非エンジニアの方からのご質問です。
早速mulmo codeをインストールしてみたそうですね。
claude codeの有料プランにも課金して、とりあえずいろいろ触ってみているとのことです。
他の方の使い方を参考にしながら、自分でもできることや、やりたいことをいろいろ試してみます、と書かれています。
claude codeに課金したからには、課金した分くらいはしっかり使い倒したい、という意気込みが伝わってきます。
これに対しての回答です。
コメントありがとうございます。
ぜひとも使い倒してください。
ぜひとも、自分専用のアプリケーションをMulmoClaudeのコレクション機能を使って作ってみてください。
ChatGPTを使っているだけのときとは、けた違いの深さでエーアイに触れることができると思います。
続いてのご質問です。
こんしゅう号で、エーアイを使った株式投資について、もし取り組むとすれば、保有株のカバード・コールを市場価格と理論価格の差から利ざやを取るような手法になるだろうという、かなり具体的な見立ても書かれていましたが、実際には、始めてしまうと意識が投資の方に向いてしまうのが目に見えているので、あえて手を出していないというお話がとても印象に残った、というお声をいただきました。
そこでご質問ですが、株式投資以外でも、効果や利益が期待できても、継続的に注意を奪われることになるからこそ、あえて見送った技術や活動はありますか。
逆に、導入後に必要となる注意が少なかったことが決め手になって導入したものがあれば、あわせて教えてほしい、とのことです。
ご自身も、エーアイは注意を節約する道具である一方で、これまで手を出しにくかった領域に簡単に取り組めるようになることで、逆に注意を分散させるツールにもなり得る、と感じていらっしゃるそうです。
このご質問への回答です。
難しい質問ですね。
ビジネスや製品のアイデアはたくさん思いつくのですが、これまで実際に実行に移せたのは、たぶん全体の二パーセントぐらいでした。
でも、賢いエーアイが誕生したことで、それが大体十パーセントから二十パーセントぐらいに増えた感覚があります。
ただ、あまりたくさんのプロジェクトに手を出し過ぎてしまうと、「廃人」のように働くことになってしまうので、それだけは避けたいと思います。
次のメッセージはご質問ではないのですが、メルマガ内でたびたび紹介していたMulmoClaudeについて、遅ればせながら利用を始めてみました、というご報告です。
さっそく、
・育児記録用のスマホアプリ
・カード利用明細の管理
・定期健診の検査結果の写真
・資産額のメモ
こうした手元のデータをもとに、それぞれ時系列での記録やダッシュボード、気づきやアドバイスなどを表示できるアプリ群を作ってみたとのことです。
メルマガ購読を始めてから、中島さんのアドバイスを参考にノーコードコーディングでアプリ作成を試してこられたそうですが、これまで数時間からいちにちかかっていたアプリ作成が、ほんの数分でできるようになり、さらにクオリティも劇的に上がり、控えめに言っても大変感動されているとのことです。
便利だからこそ、アイデアもどんどん湧いてきてワクワクしますし、まだ使い始めてほんの数日ですが、もうすでにMulmoClaudeとMulmoClaudeで作ったアプリ群が「自分にとってなくてはならないもの」になっているそうです。
これはきっと、今後確実に世の中に広まっていくサービスだと思いました、というお声もいただきました。
とても便利で画期的なツールをリリースしていただいてありがとうございます、というコメントです。
このご報告への回答です。
フィードバックありがとうございます。
開発者として、こんなフィードバックをいただけるのがいちばんの励みになります。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。